temps avec jean claude félix et tchikaya
chercheurs alips et monsieur félix
tchicaya bienvenue parmi nous merci
alors sommé de pont par souvent de
montagne qui a accouché d'une souris
quand on parle de ses sauts mais parfois
très en deçà des ambitions qu'on s'était
fixés est ce que ce sera le cas pour pau
au contraire êtes vous optimiste
l'afrique est le continent où il ya le
plus de ce sommet de forums et
malheureusement il ya une situation
continental qui reste très compliquée
pour revenir sur le g5 sahel on peut
dire que pau on espère que ce sera donc
le sommet de la clarification réciproque
le sommet de la redéfinition stratégique
commune avec j'espère que la diplomatie
depuis quelques semaines depuis cette
convocation très controversé qui était
complètement rétrograde et anna et
anachronique a blessé des millions de
citoyens africains pas seulement du
sahel
la mission de pau s'est trouvé un accord
et se réunifie est un petit peu la
géopolitique des dirigeants sauf que la
géopolitique des peuples au sahel ben
même si les avis ne sont pas
monolithiques ne sont pas tous les mêmes
il ya quand même un questionnement sur
la présence sur la stratégie militaire
beaucoup de questions se posent beaucoup
de questions se posent est celle siens
pourquoi malgré la présence étrangère
les attentats se multiplient dans la
zone 1 mali tchad niger burkina faso on
a peut-être la mauritanie qui semble
épargner mon a quand même des attentats
qui se multiplient ces derniers temps
oui 2019 ses 4000 morts des milliers
d'écoles fermées ou qui ne peuvent pas
ouvrir à cause d insécurité cédé 1,2
million de personnes déplacées des
économies déstabilisés mais aussi des
états qui ont une responsabilité parce
que ils ne sont pas tous démocratique il
ya beaucoup d' autocratique donc la
demande des jeux la géopolitique des
peuples s'est arrêté de soutenir des
démons
des gouvernants qu'on conteste et un
petit peu marre pour le dire un petit
peu comme ça que les aides soient se
servent pour des rentes pour se
maintenir pour se maintenir au pouvoir
donc il ya beaucoup d' états rétifs à
subventionner le g5 sahel parce qu'ils
voudraient une traçabilité des de ce
qu'ils vont donner sur le plan
budgétaire
alors on l'a vu un sentiment anti
français et anti français qui se
développe en ces derniers temps certains
par le même d'ingérence qu'en pensez
vous sentiment anti-français non c'est
plutôt sentiment qui s'affirme qu'il a
depuis plusieurs décennies mais qui se
densifie
c'est plutôt un sentiment contre la
politique française sur le plan
international les français peuvent
tranquillement se promener à niamey au
burkina faso la rencontre est vraiment
française mais comme la population
française en tendance hautement petits
français ils peuvent aussi le propre
c'est vraiment la politique étrangère de
la france que tout le monde connaît et
beaucoup ont des réprobations donc qui
dit nouveau monde
dis donc la fin d'un monde donc une
nouvelle façon d'opérer et
malheureusement la convocation n'était a
réveillé un petit peu un sentiment qu'il
a on se positionne mais le g5 sahel
c'est quand même l'addition d'états
faibles ou affaiblis donc ça ne fait pas
une force donc ils ont besoin d'une plus
grande participation est là sous l'égide
de l'union africaine et de la cedeao
d'autres pays africains mais aussi
d'autres puissances sur le plan mondial
pour faire face à l'hydre terroriste
alors on fait un colonisateur l histoire
africaine de la france est compliqué on
sait pourrait tout fait en ce sentiment
justement contre la politique africaine
en france
que doit faire part et de la fère paris
c'est de montrer des actes forts pour
dire qu'ils ne sont pas là pour les
dirigeants mais pour l'intérêt des
peuples d'afrique
parce que depuis des décennies l'afrique
a assisté cela à ciel ouvert sur une
géopolitique des dirigeants des
dirigeants qui se sont maintenues il
vient encore un qui était aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui à pau qui compte
plusieurs décennies au pouvoir qui est
contesté là il ya toute une gêne et il
ya des générations et notamment le
continent africain est un continent
jeune qui ont connu un ou deux
présidents avec des bilan famélique sur
le plan de de bilan assez profond et
positif alors le cerf une zone instable
on le sait les pays les plus pauvres
sont souvent malheureusement les
terrains les plus favorisés par les
terroristes pour sécuriser la zone
on de parler d'intervention militaire ne
faudrait il pas au contraire repenser le
développement de toute la région
oui la problématique et politique le
développement de toute la région mais
pays par pays
parce que quand vous êtes au tchad vous
n'êtes pas au burkina faso les
gouvernants sont pas les mêmes il ya des
similitudes mais vraiment il faut que
chaque gouvernants prennent leur
responsabilité la région aussi la cedeao
l'union africaine et qui d'autres
rapports qui est notre rapport à
l'afrique est convoité donc c'est pas un
continent pauvre mais c'est un continent
appauvris par les politiques locales
mais aussi international donc le
changement non de la saturation la
sidération de bouc peuple au sahel et
ailleurs c'est que tout cela change
en commençant par les relations
internationales
mais de la même façon de manière
imbriquée avec leurs gouvernants qui
sont contestés qui prennent parfois
l'argent comme rempart pour lutter pour
combattre les opposants comme lénine les
budgets comme des budgets qui vont
servir au népotisme qui vont servir à la
corruption est le peuple c'est qu'il y a
qui sous leurs pieds des richesses
incroyables convoité par le monde entier
mais sur le plan social ils vivent de
manière très difficile jean claude félix
tchicaya vous êtes chercheur alips et
merci pour ces analystes